la pluie a rendu les conditions de
circulation très difficile voire
impossible la grêle a provoqué de
nombreux dégâts chez des particuliers et
dans les exploitations agricoles il ya
eu effectivement des victimes et que
nous les déplorons évidemment
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
est inédit c'est en train de remettre
l'ensemble du réseau en fonctionnement
et avec 15000 personnes ce matin qu'ils
étaient privés d'électricité ce en train
de se résorber emmanuel macron par le
français et lance l'appel de juin pour
créer un conseil national de la
refondation sur le modèle assumé du
conseil national de la résistance chère
au général de gaulle dans l'interview
qu'il a donné à la presse quotidienne
régionale prix en dari madrid wina n'a à
aucun moment parlé de ces hordes de ces
bandes de voyous qui sont venus pour
détrousser nous avons aujourd'hui le
taux d'inflation le plus faible des pays
de la zone euro après 5 % pourquoi parce
que avec le présent de la république
nous avons anticipé cette inflation
50000 impacts de foudre ont été recensés
sur tout le territoire selon météo
france
en seine-et-marne elle a frappé cette
maison provoquant un spectaculaire
incendie pour le reste l'économie
française est solide nous aurons une
croissance positive en 2010 à 2 ça je
réviserai le chiffre est entendu à la
baisse viserait le chiffre parce que il
était de 4% il est évident qu'avec la
guerre en ukraine l'inflation tout cela
va remettre en cause les perspectives la
situation à severodvinsk où les combats
de rue se poursuivre reste extrêmement
difficile elle est également difficile à
l'isic chance qu marinca okura covo et
d'autres villes et communautés du
donbass moins dramatique près de
chartres
ce pèlerinage de milliers puis dell a dû
s'interrompre au son de la cornemuse
à vincennes à l'est de paris ce festival
de musique a lui aussi dû s'arrêter par
mesure de sécurité
vous avez envie ah oui le tracé la route
1 de chercher un autre horizon lointain
tel centre horizon à vous j'ai pas vu
autant d'événements horizon c'est pas
mon horizon sur un marché à montargis
dans le loiret l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer a été aspergé de crème
chantilly les auteurs deux enseignants
au fond tout ça banalise et certains
pensent des enseignants qui n'est pas
légitime de vouloir entartré l'ancien
ministre de l'éducation diable c'est
insupportable je le condamne fermement
une campagne électorale est un moment de
bonheur démocratique par les changes ça
se passe bien ici à montargis à la
rencontre des citoyens je viens d'être
agressé par deux individus qui veulent
casser cela ne l'acceptons pas vive le
calme vive le respect vive la démocratie
voire des enseignants commettre ces
actes là alors qu'ils sont ceux qui
portent
l'émancipation individuelle par les
apprentissages qui porte les valeurs de
la république c'est triste mais ils ne
sont pas représentatifs des enseignants
la veille marine le pen a été visée par
un g 2 face à saint-amand-les-eaux dans
le nord puis on sera nombreux à
l'assemblée nationale et puis on pourra
contrecarrer la politique totalement
toxiques
qu'emmanuel macron s'apprête à aggraver
lors de son deuxième mandat
jean luc mélenchon c'est comme marine le
pen ce sont des jumeaux de la peur
depuis des années ils squattent les
plateaux de télé le débat politique
qu'ils empoisonnent il search des peurs
blanchon ils surfent sur la peur des
jeunes face à la transition écologique
n'est d'accord accepté ans entre les
deux jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen
pour marine le pen surfe sur la peur
sécuritaire la peur migratoires je vais
pas vous dire qu'on va renverser la
table avoir une majorité absolue à nous
tous seuls ce que je sais c'est que plus
nous serons nombreux le député de la
droite et du centre indépendant sans
rejoindre la majorité présidentielle la
majorité parlementaire on pourra se
faire entendre en 2021 le ministère de
l'intérieur avait recensé 1100 86 élus
victimes de violence et surtout que
monsieur macro ne décidera plus tout
seul comme il l'a fait pendant cinq ans